with the Martian out now let's take a
look at 15 things you probably didn't
know about Ridley Scott's big-screen
adaptation of Andy Weir's best-selling
book director Ridley Scott didn't want
to rely on visual effects for the
sandstorm scene and wanted to make it
feel real for the act as an audience so
giant fans were use to fill the air with
dirt and stones dust got everywhere
including inside the air vents in the
actors helmets which made it tough for
them to breathe so between takes
wardrobe assistants had to help them
remove the helmets and the thick dust in
the air also meant the actors could
hardly see each other while filming
fortunately the mini intercom system
installed inside their helmets allowed
them to talk to each other and Scott
throughout according to kate mara who
plays astronaut beth johansson the cast
used the intercom to swap jokes and
tease each other which helped them bond
quickly on set the sandstorm scene took
three days to film on the Martian
exterior sets that was built on one of
the biggest sound stages in the world
stage 6 at Corder studios near Budapest
as Matt Damon plays astronaut Mark
Watney who gets stranded by himself on
Mars he spent most of his time filming
alone without the rest of the cast for a
total of nearly 5 weeks in fact his
filming schedule only coincided with
Jessica Chastain and the other actors
playing astronauts for three days in
mid-december 2014 and he filmed again
would just Chastain for a couple more
days in February 2015
after plans to film and the Australian
outback didn't work out the filmmakers
decided to shoot many of the Martian
sequences on sets to give them more
control over the environment however the
movie also filmed panoramic views for
eight days in Jordan's Wadi Rum desert
which doubled for Mars other movies that
are shot in the same area include David
Lean's Lawrence of Arabia and the sci-fi
horror the last days on Mars back in the
studio a huge green screen over 300 foot
long and 65 foot high was assembled so
background plates of weidy room could be
added and to ensure that shots taken on
the stage matched those from Jordan the
movies visual effects supervisor and
cinematographer
studied Wadi runs solar path charts so
they knew the correct lighting direction
at all times 4000 tons of soil and other
materials were used to create the
Martian landscape set it took three
types of Hungarian soil mixed together
by hand and machine to get the right
color soil to match the Wadi Rum desert
a nursery with artificial lighting and
heating was also built at the studio to
grow watney's potatoes using hard cuts
birds just like in the movie a total of
1200 potatoes were grown with around 8
potatoes per plant
the Martians Rover was modeled on the
Curiosity rover though the movies
version is even bigger a team of 22
technicians from the movie crew and 15
members of the Hungarian Opel Dakar team
constructed to full-scale Rovers for
filming but before shooting began in
Jordan the vehicles ability to deal with
rough terrain was put to the test in a
Hungarian quarry while the solar panels
on the vehicles exterior make it look as
if it runs on solar energy which has
passed the story in reality it had a 2
liter diesel engine the design of the
Hemi spacecraft was influenced by the
interlocking modules of the
International Space Station the hammies
set was built on several stages at Korda
studios and the craft bright white
interior is a nod to director Stanley
Kubrick's classic sci-fi 2001 a Space
Odyssey to make it look like the actors
were floating around in zero gravity an
enormous winch system was built and
suspended above the roofless set of the
Hermes spacecraft and the actors were
harnessed to wire rigs at the waist legs
and shoulders although the system was
mechanized members of the stunt team
were still needed to pull harness ropes
to make the actors move vertically a
hundred and fifty meters of trust 90
meters of track 70 pulleys and around
400 meters of rope were used to build
the rig to get inspiration for the movie
spacesuits costume designer John T Yates
visited NASA facilities research
spacesuit designs with the curator of
space history at the Smithsonian
National Air and Space Museum and even
saw designs for suits that are going to
be used on missions beyond 2013 15 suits
were made for the film
and the actors wore them for around ten
hours a day the surface suits worn for
exploring Mars in the film are made of
neoprene which is also used for wetsuits
the movies extra vehicular activity suit
or outer space suit which was worn
outside to Hermes is a more streamlined
less bulky version of the extra
vehicular mobility units worn by
astronauts on spacewalks at the
International Space Station underneath
the suits there was a system of cold
water tubes to keep the actors cool and
fans inside their life-support backpacks
also channelled air through a hose into
their helmets which was pretty much the
same as a cooling system used in
interstellar space suits and if you want
to check out some more cool facts and
things you didn't know about
interstellar click right here to get
good clear close-ups of the actors faces
the helmets made for the movie had to be
bigger than the ones worn by real
astronauts also each helmets visor had
to be flawless and ultra polished to
prevent the kind of glare that makes it
very difficult to capture the faces of
real astronauts on camera when they're
in space again to keep the actors faces
visible while filming the helmets also
had several lights in them which were
operated separately by small remotes
the filmmakers worked closely with NASA
from script to shoot for example they're
allowed to film rocket launches at Cape
Canaveral including the liftoff of the
Orion a spacecraft designed to
eventually enable human exploration of
Mars in fact on board the Orion during
its maiden voyage in December 2014 was a
title page of the Martian script which
included a sketch of astronaut Mark
Watney by director Ridley Scott to
prepare for her role as commander Lewis
leader of the Mars mission Jessica
Chastain spent a number of days at
NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory and the
Johnson Space Center and got to go
inside a Mars ascent vehicle Chastain
also did background reading on
astronauts including Sally Ride and
spent time with astronaut and chemist
Tracy Caldwell Dyson who shared her
experience of both the technical and
human side of life in space on top of
that via a virtual reality headset
Chastain experienced panoramic images of
Mars taken by the Curiosity rover
production designer Arthur max found
much of his inspiration for the movies
NASA sets on a tour of the Johnson Space
Center led by dr. James Greene who as
well as being director of NASA's
Planetary Science Division also happens
to be a huge fan of alien during the
tour max spoke with lots of specialists
and took hundreds of photos for
reference he also inspected the old
Apollo Mission Control Center and the
current center and incorporated aspects
of those into his own vision of NASA's
next Control Room in the Martian during
filming the monitors in the movies
Mission Control Room displayed a mixture
of graphics high-res satellite imagery
and video footage from NASA Ridley Scott
preferred this to use in green-screen
and adding the images in post-production
as it allowed him to use the images on
the screens as light sources and it gave
the actors something real to react to by
the way director Colin Trevorrow did
something similar in Jurassic world and
if you'd like to find out more things
you didn't know about that movie click
right here filming in Budapest also took
place at the whale a cultural and
commercial center located along the
river Danube the state-of-the-art
building was used for scene sets in the
offices of NASA director Teddy Saunders
and Media Relations Director Annie
Montrose played by Jeff Daniels and
Kristen Wiig and it was also used for
scenes involving conference rooms a
break room and coffee shop and the main
entrance to make the maximum use of the
buildings open spaces fake concrete
walls were placed on wheels and used to
quickly create and then change the
layout of offices as needed with filming
kate mara was already such a huge fan of
Ridley Scott before she was even cast in
the Martian that she named one of her
dogs Lucius after the Emperor's nephew
in the oscar-winning historical drama
gladiator now let me know in the
comments below what's your favorite
sci-fi movies and what other movies
would you like me to cover in my things
you didn't know videos if you enjoyed
this video do please share it hit the
thumbs-up button and subscribe for more
things you didn't know as well as movie
reviews and interviews thanks for
watching
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers